[Music]
everybody knows a great movie when they
see it but sometimes it's hard to put
your finger on what exactly made it work
we usually judge effective moments based
on their shot composition character
choices or dialogue but sometimes
powerful thematic choices come in
unexpected ways in the opening scene of
the Godfather the light hits Amerigo in
a way that makes him look like a rat
emphasizing his betrayal of the Italian
Way of life but the most powerful moment
comes later in the scene it took over a
minute to understand that America is at
odds with his Italian identity but for
Vito it takes us only a tiny moment to
learn just as much about him all it took
was a wave of his hand
like many cinematic techniques a hand
can convey a lot of visual information
depending on the context it can
symbolize power the unknown or affection
and you can even see it in action 80
years ago in 1936 Chevrolet released a
sponsored documentary film titled master
hands showing the work that goes behind
making a Chevrolet car the film focuses
on the hands of anonymous workers as
they build a car from beginning to end
from the master hands of the tool makers
machine at the end of the documentary
hands clutched the newly finished car
and drive off the film shoots the hands
on the steering wheel the same way it
shot the hands making the car and this
association of hands sends a clear
message to consumers
Chevy's are sold to the same blue-collar
hands that also make them carrying their
producers of the car with the consumers
of the car also supports the idea that a
worker directly benefits from the work
they put in but in 1936 the workers
didn't feel that way the mid-1930s
actually had some of the most violent
worker strikes in American history in
his article hands off the machine
historian max Fraser talks about the use
of hands in the art of the 1930s to
symbolize the working class the
instincts to associate hands with the
working class makes sense
most low-paying jobs required tedious
manual labor and artists saw the effect
of those jobs in people's hands in media
at the time there are generally two
types of hands in master hands they show
the benefits of manual labor
they look productive and efficient
helping to create a car in the end in
film hands don't challenge their
mistreatment or act on their own the
hands are almost extensions of the
machines themselves repetitive and
complacent in their singular tasks but
those hands were much more oppressed
than the documentary implies the workers
filmed in master hands actually went on
strike the following year now the hands
are the second type not working hands
but protesting hands free to move as
they please a hands not performing
manual labor has a completely different
symbolic meaning than the working one
instead of doing tasks for a corporation
these hands act on their own free to do
what they want it makes sense that these
free hands became a symbol that labor
parties and communists embraced when a
free Hinch doesn't perform work its
resisting the status quo these two kinds
of hands reflect the level of control
that a person has either their hands do
what they're told like in master hands
or they resist and act on their own like
during a workers strike and we see this
duel symbolism of the hand in feature
film because a hand is such a good way
to show a person acting on their own
self-interest a hand oftentimes
represents a person's control or a lack
of control of course hands and movies
don't always have to contain some grand
symbolic meaning but if you approach
them from this angle you may see some
patterns in how they're used every human
has hands so it's a pretty accessible
symbol in popular culture that
filmmakers use in a variety of contexts
the symbolic power of hands is almost
unlimited
[Music]
visually speaking the force essentially
functions as hand superpowers Vader
chokes an adversary from afar with just
a small pinch of his fingers and uses
his hands to stop lasers in their tracks
the force extends the users physical
control into their environments not only
are you in control of yourself but you
can literally control others it's the
ultimate way to show power
so if hands give people control then
losing a hand does the opposite losing
your hand in a Star Wars film means much
more because hands are such a symbol of
power without his hand we feel unsure if
Luke will regain the same mastery over
the force that he had earlier it's the
total loss of control of his hands that
contributes to the feeling of defeat at
the end of an empire while Vader wants
to sever Luke's powerful hand
Sauron wants to empower the hand in Lord
of the Rings the most powerful tool is
not a crown or a necklace it's a ring a
ring empowers a person's hand in the
same way that a tool raised in the air
empowers a factory worker but ultimately
a hand wearing a ring is not a free hand
and by creating desire for power the
ring ironically enslaves not unlike the
factory workers under the control of
their company fantasy films use hands
and the extension of a person's hands to
show power or the lack of it and that
includes the most popular franchise in
recent memory like the ring and the
force the Infinity Gauntlet gets a lot
of its symbolic strength by focusing on
the hand the gauntlet feels like one of
the most intimidating weapons put to
film because it extends the control of a
hand into control of the fabric of the
entire universe it's certainly cool that
Thanos can use the gauntlet to control
moons you throw another moon at me I'm
gonna lose it but we see his power the
most when he does so much more with such
a little gesture with a simple snap of
his fingers he alters the course of the
entire universe
it's basically the opening of the
Godfather on steroids both fan OHS and
Vito essentially used their hands in the
same way before Vito speaks he gives a
command with his hands to get Amerigo a
drink with such a small gesture he can
control the world around him the hand
movement shows Vito's power precisely
because the gesture is so small by
placing the hand in the foreground it
dominates the scene and conveys visual
Authority when Vito does his gesture
Amerigo is literally in the palm of his
hands paul thomas anderson uses a
similar method in there will be blood he
often centers the frame on the hand to
subtly communicate important bits of
information while a different film might
cut to close-ups of faces or the map
anderson has the confidence to stick to
this wide shot and use hands to direct
our eyes and if anyone's hands command
attention throughout the scene it's dan
use he doesn't even have to directly
face the camera to command the screen
when he goes to shake Paul's hand his
hand cuts across the frame preventing
Eli from leaving this motion feels
aggressive despite just being a
handshake it's a small example of
Daniels manipulative personality
disguised as just the simple work of a
businessman throughout the rest of the
film Daniels hands are a main focus for
his character he regularly points grabs
and slaps
and he always does so to express his
authority the film follows the power
struggle between him and Eli so it makes
sense that they use their hands to
attempt to take control and this scene
Daniel asserts his authority and Eli
stands by looking powerless with his
hands a little lower than the center of
the frame in many ways they are like the
hands of America also tightly contained
the one big difference though is that
americo's hands tremble and move around
randomly while Eli remains steady it
turns out that Eli was only holding back
and we see the true power of his hands
when he leads Church here he has the
authority to point grab and even slap
Daniel at this point in the film Eli has
just as much power but of course it's
Daniel who wins in the end
and once again his hands dominate the
frame I drink your milkshake but
thinking about hands only as a symbol of
a power dynamic and sells them short
many of the most famous hands in movie
histories don't necessarily fit into
that idea the problem is that we've been
thinking of hands as an extension of the
power of a human but what if the hand
isn't even human in the first place and
what if the hand isn't even attached to
anything there's a common horror trope
of the severed hand that still moves
there's something frightening about a
hand without its master
possibly because it literally has a mind
of its own if a hand represents control
then loosing control of your hands would
be the ultimate loss of agency unusual
hands make their way into the horror
genre because we all have an
understanding of what a hand should be
and it's the part of our body we use the
most for everyday tasks an understanding
of what's normal and common gives the
filmmaker the opportunity to show that
someone or something is abnormal in
district 9 wicked starts turning into an
alien after accidentally spraying
himself with a mysterious liquid so
which body part becomes alien first
and as expected his hands changing means
he can now fire alien weapons not only
do his hands represent the abnormal but
they still show the classic power
dynamic ET introduces the idea that an
alien hand doesn't have to be evil
before ET aliens almost always appeared
as the villain and their foreign hands
meant they were a threat to the norm but
each uses his hands to show his trust
and Eliot
like King Kong it challenges the
assumption that a foreign hand has to be
an evil one we've been ignoring the most
important reason for hands the kind of
hands we hopefully see most often in our
everyday lives the trusting hands hands
are an easy way to visualize cooperation
it goes against the idea that hands are
used to dominate a situation they can
also show cooperation and affection hand
touching isn't always cold and
power-hungry like the kiss of death a
movie like Call Me by your name feels so
warm and loving because characters
regularly touch and hold each other and
not just in a romantic way Ellie OS dad
speaks to him in a surprisingly tender
way about his relationship and as the
scene fades out he reaches out to touch
him in contrast the dad and American
Beauty never touches anybody once he
finally does it's in such an awkward and
unfulfilled way or maybe the dad's hand
is too controlling
oh my fin old my fin Marlin in Finding
Nemo has to accept that he can never
entirely control and protect Nemo we see
his conflict manifested literally when
he holds on to the whales tongue but
instead of a hand
it's a flipper
so hands really are the visible part of
the brain if some people literally use
their hands as a language I don't think
it's much of a stretch to think that
filmmakers can use hands to communicate
complicated ideas control good or the
lack of it
the foreign or the familiar the loving
or the sassy ones it's definitely a
weird way to look at a scene but who
knows maybe one day it'll come in handy
I'm not sure what to do with my hand be
good just hold him down by your side
yeah great of course the symbolic
history of hands goes back much further
in other art forms there's a fascinating
history behind the study of hands in art
during the Renaissance era artists like
Michelangelo and da Vinci had a fixation
on the anatomy of the hand that was both
scientific and aesthetic I definitely
recommend checking out the documentary
the Renaissance factor because it goes
into details beyond the scope of this
video it's a fascinating watch that
outlines the advances in organ science
that prompted this focus on Anatomy
you can watch it on curiosity straight
curiosity streams newly expanded library
has thousands of titles that will send
you down the rabbit hole on topics like
arts science and history go to curiosity
stream comm slash now you see it and
enter the promo code now you see it when
prompted during the signup process your
membership is completely free for the
first 30 days with our code plus it
helps us out too and as always thanks to
our patrons for your support if you're
considering supporting the channel check
out our patreon to get early access to
videos and behind-the-scenes content
thanks for watching
[Music]